Bueno, voy a hablar acerca de un problema que tengo
y es que soy filósofo.
(Risas)
Cuando voy a una fiesta y la gente me pregunta lo que hago
y digo "catedrático", sus ojos se ponen vidriosos.
Cuando voy a un cóctel de académicos
y todos los catedráticos están allí y me preguntan en qué campo trabajo,
y digo "filosofía" sus ojos se ponen vidriosos.
(Risas)
Cuando voy a una fiesta de filósofos
y me preguntan sobre qué trabajo y digo "la conciencia",
sus ojos no se ponen vidriosos... pero sus labios hacen una mueca de disgusto.
(Risas)
y recibo carcjadas de burla y risitas y refunfuños
porque piensan, "¡eso es imposible! No se puede explicar la conciencia."
¡Qué descaro de que alguien crea
que se puede explicar la conciencia cuando es totalmente imposible!
Mi recientemente fallecido y añorado amigo Bob Nozick, un muy buen filósofo,
en uno de sus libros "Explicaciones Filosóficas,"
comenta el ethos de la filosofía,
y la forma en que los filósofos hacen sus cosas.
Y dice, saben, "los filósofos aman la argumentación racional".
Y añade, "Parece que la discusión ideal
para la mayoría de los filósofos es darle a su audiencia las premisas
y luego darles las inferencias y la conclusión,
y si no aceptan la conclusión, mueren.
Sus cabezas explotan. "La idea es tener un argumento
que sea tan poderoso que noquee a tus oponentes.
Pero la verdad es que eso no cambia la opinión de la gente para nada.
Es muy difícil cambiar la opinión de la gente
sobre algo como la conciencia,
y finalmente comprendí el porqué de este fenómeno.
La razón es que todos somos expertos sobre la conciencia
El otro día escuchamos que todo el mundo tiene una opinión fuerte sobre los videojuegos.
Todos tienen una idea para un videojuego, aunque no sean expertos.
Pero ellos no se consideran expertos en videojuegos,
simplemente tienen opiniones fuertes.
Estoy seguro que la gente presente que trabaja en, digamos, el cambio climático
y el calentamiento global, o sobre el futuro de internet,
se encuentra con gente que tiene opiniones muy fuertes
acerca de lo que va a pasar en el futuro cercano.
Pero probablemente no creen que son opiniones expertas.
Sólo expresan convicciones profundas.
Pero en relación a la conciencia, la gente parece pensar,
cada uno de nosotros parece pensar, "Yo soy un experto.
Simplemente por estar consciente, lo sé todo sobre esto."
Y así, uno les cuenta su teoría y ellos dicen,
"¡No, no, la conciencia no es así!
No, estás completamente equivocado."
Y lo dicen con una seguridad increible.
Así que lo que intentaré hacer hoy
es perturbar su confianza. Porque conozco la sensación...
La puedo sentir en mí mismo
Quiero perturbar su confianza de que conocen lo más íntimo de sus mentes...
y de que pueden hablar con autoridad sobre sus propias conciencias.
Esa es la orden del día aquí.
Ahora, esta bonita imagen muestra una globo de pensamiento. Una burbuja de pensamiento.
Creo que todo el mundo entiende lo que esto significa.
Se supone que muestra el flujo de nuestra conciencia.
Esta es mi representación favorita de la conciencia que se haya hecho jamás.
Es de Saul Steinberg, por supuesto... fue portada del New Yorker.
Y este tipo aquí esta mirando el cuadro de Braque.
Eso le recuerda a la palabra barroco, barro, perro, caniche,
Suzanne R. y se va a las carreras.
Aquí hay un flujo de conciencia magnífico
y si lo siguen, aprenden mucho sobre este hombre.
Lo que también me gusta en particular de este dibujo
es que Steinberg ha presentado a este hombre
en un estilo algo puntillista.
Lo que nos recuerda, como Rod Brooks decía ayer,
que lo que somos, lo que cada uno de nosotros es, lo que ustedes son, lo que yo soy...
es aproximadamente 100 billones de robots celulares.
Eso es de lo que estamos hechos.
No hay ningún otro ingrediente. Estamos hechos sólo de células, alrededor de 100 billones de ellas.
Ninguna de esas células es consciente,
ninguna de esas células sabe quien eres tú, ni le importa.
De algún modo, tenemos que explicar
cómo cuando creas equipos, ejércitos, batallones
de cientos de millones de pequeñas células robóticas inconscientes...
en realidad, no muy diferente de una bacteria cada uno de ellos...
el resultado es éste. ¡Mírenlo!
El contenido: hay color, hay ideas, hay recuerdos,
hay historia. Y de alguna manera todo ese contenido de la conciencia
se consigue con la ajetreada actividad de esas hordas de neuronas.
¿Cómo es posible? Mucha gente sencillamente cree, que no es posible en absoluto.
Piensan, "No, no puede haber ningún
tipo de explicación naturalista de la conciencia".
Hay un libro fantástico de un amigo mío llamado Lee Siegel
que enseña religión, de hecho, en la Universidad de Hawaii,
y es un mago experto, y un experto
sobre la magia callejera de la India, que es el tema del libro,
"Red de Magia"
Y hay un pasaje que quisiera compartir con ustedes.
Habla muy elocuentemente sobre este problema.
"Estoy escribiendo un libro sobre magia", explico, y me preguntan, ¿Magia de verdad?
Por 'magia de verdad' la gente se refiere a milagros,
actos taumatúrgicos y poderes sobrenaturales.
"No", contesto. "Prestidigitación, no magia de verdad".
La magia de verdad, en otras palabras, se refiere a una magia que no es real,
mientras que la magia que es real, la que realmente puede hacerse, no es magia de verdad".
(Risas)
Ahora bien, así se sienten muchos con respecto a la conciencia.
La verdadera conciencia no es un libro de trucos.
Si vas a explicarlo como un libro de trucos,
entonces no es conciencia de verdad, sea lo que sea.
Y como dijo Marvin, y como han dicho otros:
"La conciencia es un libro de trucos".
Esto significa que hay muchos que quedan completamente insatisfechos.
e incrédulos cuando intento explicar la conciencia.
Así que este es el problema, debo intentar
hacer un poco del tipo de trabajo
que a muchos no les gustará,
por el mismo motivo que no les gusta
que les expliquen un truco de magia.
¿Cuántos de los aquí presentes, si alguien (un sabelotodo)
les empiezara a explicar como se hace un truco en particular,
querrían taparse los oídos y decir, "¡No, no, no quiero saberlo!
No le quites la gracia, prefiero que sea un misterio.
No me cuentes el secreto"
Hay muchos que se sienten así sobre la conciencia, como he comprobado.
Y pido disculpas si les estoy imponiendo algo de claridad o comprensión.
Si prefieren no saber algunos de estos trucos es mejor que se vayan ahora.
Pero no se lo explicaré todo.
Haré lo que hacemos los filósofos.
Así explica un filósofo cómo se parte en dos a una mujer con serrucho.
¿Conocen ese truco?
El filósofo dice, "Yo les explicaré como se hace:
Verán, el mago no serraba de verdad a la mujer en dos".
(Risas)
"Sólo les hace creer que lo hace".
Y ustedes dicen, "¿Ah sí?, ¿y cómo lo hace?"
Y el responde, "oh, eso es de otro departamento, lo siento."
(Risas)
Así que ahora intentaré explicar cómo los filósofos explican la conciencia.
Pero también intentaré mostrarles
que la conciencia no es tan maravillosa,
que su propia conciencia no es tan extraordinaria
como pueden haber creído.
Esto es algo que, por cierto, Lee Siegel comenta en su libro.
Se maravilla de cómo después de uno de sus espectáculos
la gente jura que le vieron hacer X, Y o Z. El nunca hizo nada de eso.
Ni siquiera intentó hacerlo.
La memoria de las personas exagera lo que creen haber visto.
Y lo mismo ocurre con la conciencia.
Ahora veamos si esto funciona. Bien, echemos un vistazo.
Miren con atención.
Estoy trabajando con un jóven animador por ordenador y documentalista
llamado Nick Dreamer, y esta es una pequeña muestra que hizo para mi,
parte de un proyecto mayor que puede interesarles a algunos.
Estamos buscando patrocinador...
Es un largometraje documental sobre la conciencia.
Ahora bien, todos han visto lo que cambió, ¿cierto?
¿Cuántos de ustedes se han percatado de que cada uno de los cuadrados ha cambiado de color?
Todos. Se lo mostraré de nuevo.
Incluso cuando saben que todos van a cambiar de color,
es muy difícil darse cuenta. Hay que concentrarse mucho
para notar al menos alguno de los cambios.
Bien, este es un ejemplo, entre muchos,
de un fenómeno que se está estudiando bastante.
Es uno que predije en las últimas páginas de mi
libro de 1991, "La Conciencia Explicada",
donde sostenía que si se hacían experimentos de este tipo,
encontraríamos que las gente es incapaz de percibir cambios realmente grandes.
Si hay tiempo al final,
les mostraré un caso mucho más llamativo.
Ahora, ¿cómo puede ser que estén ocurriendo todos estos cambios,
y que no seamos conscientes de ellos?
Bueno, ya escuchamos hoy a Jeff Hawkins hablarnos de cómo nuestros ojos saltan,
como se mueven de un lado a otro, tres o cuatro veces por segundo.
No mencionó la velocidad. Sus ojos están en constante movimiento,
moviéndose de un lado a otro, mirando a otros ojos, narices, codos,
mirando a las cosas interesantes en el mundo.
Y ahí donde no miran nuestros ojos,
tenemos una visión notablemente empobrecida.
Esto se da porque la parte foveal del ojo,
que es la parte de alta resolución,
es del tamaño de la uña de su pulgar con el brazo estirado.
Esa es la parte de los detalles.
Pero no parece ser así, ¿no es cierto?
No parece ser así, pero así es.
Están recibiendo bastante menos información de la que creen.
Aquí pueden ver un ejemplo muy diferente. Éste es un cuadro de Bellotto.
Está en el museo de Carolina del Norte.
Bellotto fue discípulo de Canaletto.
Y me encantan este tipo de cuadros.
El cuadro es más o menos del mismo tamaño que el que aparece aquí.
Y me encantan los Canalettos, porque tienen un nivel de detalle fantástico.
y uno puede acercárse bien
y distinguir todos los detalles.
Y a mi me atrajo desde el otro lado del pasillo en Carolina del Norte
porque pensé que probablemente era un Canaletto,
y tendría todo ese detalle.
Y me fijé que en ese puente, hay mucha gente,
uno apenas puede verlos cruzando el puente.
Y mientras me acercaba pensaba
que podría ver al detalle a la mayoría de las personas,
su ropa y demás.
Y al acercarme más y más, de hecho grité.
Grité porque al acercarme
descubrí que el detalle no estaba.
Sólo eran unas gotas de pintura aplicadas con gran habilidad artística.
Y mientras caminaba hacia el cuadro
esperaba un nivel de detalle inexistente.
El artista había sugerido con gran habilidad a las personas y sus ropas
y vagones y todo tipo de cosas
y mi cerebro se creyó la sugerencia.
Ustedes están familiarizados con una tecnología más reciente, que está... ahí.
Pueden ver mejor las gotas.
Vean, cuando se acercan,
en realidad son sólo gotas de pintura.
Habrán visto cosas como estas, este es el efecto contrario.
Se lo mostraré una vez más.
Ahora, ¿qué hace su cerebro cuando acepta la sugerencia?
Cuando una hábil gota o dos, por un artista,
sugieren a una persona... digamos un miembro de
la sociedad de la mente de Marvin Minsky,
¿se envían pequeños pintores para que completen los detalles en alguna parte de sus cerebros?
No lo creo. Imposible. Pero entonces, ¿cómo diablos lo hacen?
Bueno, ¿recuerdan la explicación del filósofo sobre la mujer partida en dos?
Es lo mismo.
El cerebro simplemente les hace creer que ahí está el detalle.
Creen que el detalle está, pero no lo está.
El cerebro no está realmente creando los detalles en tu cabeza.
Sólo está haciendo que esperes el detalle.
Hagamos este experimento rápidamente.
¿La forma de la izquierda es la misma que la de la derecha, pero rotada?
Sí.
¿Cuántos de ustedes lo han hecho rotando la de la izquierda
mentalmente, para ver si correspondía con la de la derecha?
¿Cuántos lo han hecho con la de la derecha? Vale.
¿Cómo saben que es eso lo que han hecho?
(Risas)
De hecho ha habido un debate muy interesante
en las ciencias cognitivas de los últimos 20 años;
varios experimentos creados por Roger Sheperd,
que medían la velocidad angular de rotación de las imágenes mentales.
Sí, se puede hacer.
Pero los detalles del proceso todavía crean mucha controversia.
Y si leen lo escrito sobre el tema, una de las cosas
que debemos aceptar es que
incluso cuando uno es el sujeto del experimento, uno no sabe.
No sabe cómo lo hace.
Sólo sabemos que tenemos ciertas creencias.
Y que vienen en un cierto orden, en cierto momento.
¿Y qué explica el hecho de que eso es lo que pensamos?
Bueno, ahí es donde hay que ir tras las bambalinas a preguntarle al mago.
Esta es una figura que me encanta: Bradley, Petrie y Dumais.
Pueden pensar que he hecho algo de trampa,
que he puesto un borde más blanco que el blanco ahí.
¿Cuántos de ustedes ven un borde así,
con el cubo de Necker flotando delante de los círculos?
¿Lo ven?
Bueno, deben saber que, en efecto, el borde realmente esá ahí en cierto sentido.
Su cerebro de hecho procesa el borde,
el borde que iría exactamente ahí...
Pero ahora fíjense que hay dos formas de ver el cubo, ¿verdad?
Es un cubo de Necker.
¿Pueden ver todos las dos formas de verlo? Vale.
¿Pueden ver las cuatro formas de ver el cubo?
Porque hay otra forma de verlo.
Si lo están viendo como un cubo flotando delante de unos círculos,
unos círculos negros, hay otra forma de verlo.
Como un cubo sobre un fondo negro,
como se vería a través de un pedazo de queso suizo.
(Risas)
¿Lo ven? ¿Cuántos no pueden verlo? Esto ayudará.
Ahora lo ven. Estos son dos fenómenos muy diferentes.
Cuando se ve el cubo de una forma, como detrás de una pantalla,
los bordes desaparecen.
Pero seguimos rellenando de algún modo, como podemos ver si miramos esto.
No nos cuesta ver esto en absoluro, pero ¿dónde cambia el color?
¿Tendrán sus cerebros que enviar pequeños pintores ahí?
¿Los pintores de morado y de verde
se pelean para ver quien pinta ese espacio detrás de la cortina? No.
Sus cerebros simplemente se desentienden. El cerebro no necesita rellenarlo.
Cuando empecé a hablar sobre
el ejemplo Bradley, Petirie, Dumais que acaban de ver...
Volveré a él, aquí está...
Dije que no había relleno ahí atrás.
Y supuse que era una verdad sólida, constante.
Pero Rob Van Lier nos ha hecho ver hace poco que no es así.
Ahora, si creen ver un amarillo pálido...
Lo haré pasar algunas veces más.
Miren en las áreas grises
y vean si ven una especie de sombras moviéndose por ahí...
¡Sí, es asombroso! No hay nada ahí. No es un truco.
["Incapacidad para Detectar Cambios en Escenas"]
Este es el trabajo de Ron Rensink, que de alguna forma
fue inspirado por la sugerencia justo al final del libro.
Permítanme pausar esto un segundo si puedo.
Esto es ceguera al cambio.
Lo que verán es dos cuadros,
uno de los cuales es levemente diferente al otro.
Pueden ver aquí el techo rojo y el techo gris,
y entre ellos habrá una máscara,
que es simplemente una pantalla en blanco, durante aproximadamente un cuarto de segundo.
De tal modo que verán el primer cuadro, luego la máscara,
a continuación el segundo cuadro, luego la máscara.
Y esto simplemente continuará, y su labor como sujeto
es apretar el botón cuando vean el cambio.
Mostramos el cuadro original durante 240 milisegundos. Pantalla en blanco.
Mostramos el siguiente durante 240 milisegundos. Pantalla en blanco.
Y así sigue hasta que el sujeto presiona el botón diciendo
"Veo el cambio"
Y ahora seremos los sujetos del experimento.
Empezaremos con algo fácil. Algunos ejemplos.
No hay problema aquí.
¿Pueden verlo todos? Bien.
De hecho los sujetos de Resnick se demoraron sólo un poco más
de un segundo en apretar el botón.
¿Pueden ver ese?
2,9 segundos
¿Cuántos siguen sin verlo?
¿Que hay sobre el techo de ese granero?
(Risas)
Es fácil.
¿Es un puente o un muelle?
Tengo algunos más llamativos, y ya termino.
Quiero que vean algunos que son particularmente impactantes.
Este, por ser tan grande y sin embargo bastante difiícil de ver.
¿Lo ven?
Publico: Sí
¿Ven las sombras moverse de un lado a otro? Bastante grande.
Así que 15 segundos y medio es la media de tiempo
de los sujetos en su experimento.
Me encanta éste. Terminaré con él,
sólo porque es algo tan obvio e importante.
¿Cuántos siguen sin verlo? ¿Cuántos siguen sin verlo?
¿Cuántos motores tiene el ala de ese Boeing?
(Risas)
¡Justo en mitad de la imagen!
Muchas gracias por su atención.
Lo que quería mostrarles es que los científicos,
usando desde fuera, sus métodos en tercera persona,
pueden decirles cosas sobre su propia conciencia
que ustedes ni hubiesen soñado.
Y que, de hecho, no son las autoridades
que creen ser sobre sus propias conciencias.
Y estamos progresando mucho
en generar una teoría de la mente.
Jeff Hawkins, esta mañana, describía su intento
de generar teoría, una buena y gran teoría, en la neurociencia.
Y tiene razón. Esto es un problema.
En la Facultad de Medicina de Harvard, una vez, estaba en una charla,
y el director del laboratorio dijo, "en nuestro laboratorio tenemos un dicho:
si trabajas sobre una neurona, eso es neurociencia,
si trabajas sobre dos, eso es psicología".
(Risas)
Debemos crear más teoría, y bien puede ser generada en gran medida desde arriba.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)